it's all about this man i'm with you
ever since he's a threat to all of us a
traitor who's it trade the Rosenbergs
are three what were they bet your sister
they gave atomic secrets to the Russians
they were Americans they betrayed their
country but you can't excuse Abel of
being a traitor he's not in America
listen to yourself you're defending him
already you're rehearsing at on me you
said you were just thinking about it I
am just thinking about it is very hard
everyone deserves a defense every person
matters Jim what do we deserve do you
know how people will look at us the
family of a man trying to free a traitor
all my friends in one place I've never
been so happy I don't love this day to
end and it doesn't have to
as long as we get rid of sky right let's
do the math our service mission here was
supposed to last 31 Sol's for redundancy
they sent 68 Sol's worth of food that's
46 people so for just me that's gonna
last 300 Sol's which I figure I can
stretch to 400 if I ration so I got to
figure out a way to grow three years
worth of food here on a planet where
nothing grows
watch the girl